[Music]
harold i don't know what you think
you're doing this excuse me hello
[Music]
got a dead white man in a box
not even a casket doesn't even have a
top on it
in a pine box of old wood
what do you think's gonna get in trouble
here
do me a favor try to be optimistic
don't get here
without things starting a long time ago
so two soldiers
and the nurse found ourselves in
amsterdam
we formed the pact and we swore to
protect each other
no matter what
we find ourselves in a situation where
we're accused of killing someone which
is not true
you and woodman fled the scene the
killer pointed at us we didn't do
anything why would you possibly think
that was us
well there's not too many people that
fit the description of a doctor looking
for his eye on the ground with his black
attorney columbia law school
love is funny we need someone to help us
to find the truth
my friend was killed
because of something monstrous that he
had seen
this is all turning out to be a lot
larger than any of us
you're gonna have to take my lead
getting out of this
i had to stab a guy i had to hit a lady
with a brick one time what
it's a long story but with you two it'll
be a cake walk
these are dangerous times you be careful
i'm about to do something that could
cost me my life
the cuckoo is in the nest and the
cuckoo's about to be trapped
cuckoo
[Music]
this is one of the finest innovations
from zurich it removes all pain
guys like me we have to turn to booze
the morphine and that can lead to
addiction oh that's fast
[Music]
you